all right so just a quick a quick couple
of thank-yous thank you to the Center
for Arts in society thanks Paul for that
introduction and an Anna for your hard
work as well thanks to Tim and Pat who
are gonna follow me I feel like you know
it's a State of the Union address and
the Republicans are gonna then get up
and say something but and it actually
you know if it's gonna if it is like the
State of the Union it won't have
anything to do with my speech at all you
know because that's kind of what the
Republicans did and also thank you to
Gerry Costanza and CMU press for for
putting out this book because without
them I couldn't have done it and and
also Jon Carson who's going to be doing
a workshop with me on Saturday as sort
of part of this whole weekend of events
okay so what I like to do is just sort
of get into talking about how I got
started as a cartoonist and then I will
tell you a little bit about how my brain
works but you know I won't show you any
like you know cat scans of brains or
anything like that but but I do have a
connection to medicine my father was a
pulmonary physician for the University
of Pittsburgh and although we were born
in Philadelphia but but we eventually
both ended up in Pittsburgh and and he
developed a process early on called lung
lavage which which it was where they
would wash out patients lungs with
saline and of course the way they did it
was they put a tube down their throat
and and washed it out but he used to ask
me to draw cartoons for him for his talk
so one time he asked me to draw
something about him and I consider this
my my sort of first editorial cartoon
it's not the first cartoon I ever drew
but boy I would have been amazing if
that was the case no this is my dad the
lung washer and this is how I drew
and of course you know of course he's
he's not he's not using the two of he's
washing them out in a bucket and a quart
then my spelling was just as good back
then as it is now as you can see there
this yeah I consider this my first
editorial cartoon because because I
actually went after somebody in power I
drew my dad without hair and he had a
full head of hair till he died but you
know this is how I depicted him and he
never quite understood why I did that
but I just looked funnier you know so so
anyway he used to use his the my
cartoons in his talks in his medical
talks because he said it helps keep
people awake during you know during the
process so I'm going to use the same
theory except in between my cartoons I'm
going to show you some lungs and this is
it this is an emphysema lung here not
very pretty but my parents knew knew
early on that I was I was a special kid
here's a photograph of me you know then
and of course you know of course my dad
my dad wasn't the only talented one in
the family my mom was pretty cool too
this is a picture her you know she was
she was the disciplinarian of course but
I'll start out by you know a little
insight into my brain besides what you
just saw but will will be how I come up
with ideas and so a lot of people ask me
that question so I I wanted to dispel
some myths about the whole creativity
process and so I came up with sort of
these these myths of creativity that I
want to dispel so so where do I get my
ideas I am always amazed people ask ask
me that question as if you know there's
a vending machine around the corner or
something with ideas in it
I wish there was but there isn't and
they don't sell them on eBay either but
you know there is no store so so here's
I sort of did a take off on Ikea it's a
big world someone's gotta furnish it
with good ideas so there is no store
there is no there are no elves that come
in the middle of the night to help me
think of ideas ideas don't just drop out
of this
there's no little switch on the back of
my head that I can turn on and off no
actually what happens is it the process
of coming up with an idea is a little
bit more like when a hunter goes out
into the woods and sort of waits for his
prey to come walking by this so you can
shoot him you know I have to sort of
read the newspapers and put all the
information in and then sort of wait for
the idea to come and so this is this I
sort of illustrate that here it's a
little bit like you know you know you
you you set you set the trap you kind of
set the trap with the you know the
newspaper the story's the headlines you
know watching the cable news getting
stories off the internet and that's kind
of the cheese and then I just wait till
the idea pops in in that trap it and
once once I have an idea that sort of
not fully formed
you know swirling around in there it
feels a little bit like being pregnant
quick call the editor my water broke and
then of course there's nothing prouder
than a cartoonist with a new-born idea
but now once I come up with an idea I
still have to get it past my editor and
and he can be pretty intimidating here's
a photo of him oftentimes oftentimes he
doesn't like the cartoon and he'll send
me back to do another one here he is
sending me back but this gets me into
the difficulty of dealing with editors
between cartoonists and editors and I
did this cartoon it's called further
evidence that cartoonists are from Mars
and editors are from Venus I did this
for an editors magazine and and this
will give you a little bit of an idea
about the difference between the
cartoonist brain and the editors brain
so first we have the cartoonist brain
and what's on the cartoonist mind are
you know the biggest part of his brain
is toilet humor then then you have
things like winning a Pulitzer keeping
his or her job and that tiny little part
of the cartoonist brain that's taste
alright then then you have the editors
brain so he's got a lot more things on
his mind he's thinking about not
offending readers keeping the publisher
happy winning a Pulitzer kissing up to
advertisers the bottom line and that
little tiny part of the editors brain
that's sense of humor so you can see the
difference is very stark and and it
really is you know something that that
needs needs a lot of a lot of explaining
because people don't understand you know
their word people they're not they're
not visual people by trade so so what's
funny is that I have an editor one of my
editors John Allison who would always
look at my cartoon and he would never
laugh at the drawing or even comment on
the drawing he would just say oh you
missed a comma here you know so so and
we just keep a straight face and those
of you who have met him I know some of
you have you would you would understand
that and of course a newspaper we use a
style book and it's called the AP
Stylebook and so here we here he is
telling me that according to the
Associated Press poopet is two words so
so yeah John was it was not a he's not a
laugh a minute he was a very dry sense
of humor but but he is funny I mean he
can be funny that's not when he's
reading my cartoons okay so here I am
sitting at the my drawing table looking
at a story about cloning so this will
give you an idea of sort of with a
process so so I think to myself okay so
they're cloning a bunch of sheep right
so what's what's scary about that well
obviously it's not really about the
Sheep what people are worried about is
the next step so I think well what would
really scare me about cloning well this
would scare me
so but of course not everybody knows
John Allison so I have to somehow like
work that into a more topical cartoon
that everybody can understand
so back in in the 90s when Clinton was
in the White House and Newt Gingrich was
giving him a hard time
I drew this cartoon and Clinton is
saying I never should have approved
funding for those cloning experiments
and of course you got you know all these
little newts running around alright so
one of the things that people ask me
after they try to find out where I get
my ideas the next thing that they asked
me is why didn't I go into medicine so
you know with a successful father who
was the chief of pulmonary medicine you
know why didn't I go into medicine well
I finally just decided to write down and
illustrate the top ten reasons that I
didn't go into medicine and here they
are number one basically my dad's feet
were way too big you know following in
his footsteps would have been as
embarrassing as my teen years so I
decided not to do that so then number
number nine my handwriting was just too
good why is your father crying I got an
A in penmanship number eight there are
too many big words you've got some
serious disease I can't pronounce but
don't worry doctor what's his name the
whatchamacallit specialist will be along
shortly and he can tell you what it is
number seven on call is not a concept
that I embrace doesn't this damn thing
have a snooze button number six there's
too much to remember let's see how does
that song go the thigh bones connected
to the knee bone the knee bones
connected number five malpractice
insurance is too high notice anything
unusual in the x-ray doctor no I can't
see since I lost my glasses last week
number four I just hate the fashion
these would be good for a winter but I'm
really more of an autumn number three
everyone's too darn serious just make
the incision doctor and number two I
hate golf this is the last time I let
you pick the course you're just sore
because I bogeyed on the windmill and
the number one reason I did not go into
medicine there are too many bodily
fluids whose lemonade is this and what
happened to my urine sample so you'll
like this next one this is chronic
bronchitis just just something to you
know keep you awake
so basically when I look at when I look
at the body of my work and when I was
sort of like putting together this book
it was interesting to see how themes
repeated themselves but it was also
interesting to sort of latch onto which
cartoons you know I would come across
some cartoons and I would say wow that
one that one everybody liked but it was
just because they liked it because it
was funny it didn't really offend
anybody but they really liked it and
then I'd find one and I'd say oh that
one really got people pissed off so so
really you know when it comes down to it
there are kind of two groups there are
cartoons two kinds of cartoons cartoons
have pissed people off and the ones that
don't piss people off I said upset
people because you know it's a-you know
tried to be I did a library the other
day and I didn't want to you know get
people mad but anyway so I'm gonna start
out with some cartoons that do upset
people and give you sort of an idea of
what happens there
races is a topic that I that I've get
into trouble from time to time often
times because the subtlety and the the
irony or the humor is lost because the
subject matter is so serious but people
can't see beyond the fact that I'm
saying something about race which is
actually I just got a call from Katie
Kay they're doing a story about my
cartoon that ran yesterday the police
are up in arms about it and
I don't know if any of you saw the brood
on grant that I did yeah they didn't
like the part about the racist skinhead
etiquette handbook so there was about
Jordan miles in the beating that
happened in Homewood anyway it does get
me into trouble
here's one with a guy that says we
deserve reparations for slavery and the
white guy's saying hey we just gave you
people to Oscars isn't that enough
this is right after Denzel Washington
and Halle Berry won the Oscar and people
people just you know some some people
not everybody but some people in the
african-american community thought I was
saying yes this is enough you know and
of course that's not what I'm saying I'm
trying to make fun of the white guy but
it does it doesn't always come across so
I got some letters and phone calls on
this one this one I got even more
letters and phone calls this is a
southern guy talking about the
Confederate flag and he says I like to
look up the flagpole and see a symbol of
our Southern heritage hanging there
what's so wrong about that so you know
I'm obviously trying to say that the
Confederate flag there's more to it than
just a you know a symbol of the south
and and this actually was ran in in a
university paper in Oklahoma City and
the editor got fired after running it
and and they had a big stink on the news
and everything else and it was a shame
but you know they they just didn't
understand that I was actually saying
that you know that that we need to be
sensitive to these kinds of things this
is right after Katrina step the FEMA's
guide to avoiding disaster step 1 gather
up emergency rations of food water and
clothing step 2 moved to a rich white
neighborhood another topic that gets me
into plenty of trouble is religion and
you know we have a very Catholic City
here so I anytime I draw a cartoon about
the Pope it has to go through the
publisher first because he's tired of
he's tired of the bishop calling and
yelling at him so wait and then that's a
true story I'm not I'm not making it up
I did get a a chewing I got chewed out
by Bishop World
back when this new Pope Benedict was
pushed first in office because I did a
cartoon about it but so here's one when
the Pope visited with Castro you're an
aging leader of a beleaguered belief
system who tolerates no dissent what do
you want from me pointers you can
imagine this one this one actually got
got notated in the in the Vatican
newsletter and they said they said how
much they hated it but here's the one
the bishop world didn't like he said I
made him look like Uncle Fester
and I I said have you looked at him no
he kind of looks like Uncle Fester but
this is something that that Benedict
actually said he said the Cardinals
elected me a simple humble worker in the
vineyard of the Lord so I just took his
quote and had him saying it but of
course he's stomping the liberal grapes
because he was much more conservative
than even John Paul and you know as it
turns out he's been a better Pope than
people thought but but it it still you
know at the time people thought this was
the case so so I got some oh wait I got
I got I thought there was a letter after
this I had one I got lots of letters on
this and some guys said that you know
look look look check your watches it
only took Rob Rogers like five minutes
to make fun of the new pope you know so
so you know people are sensitive to
anything you know whenever their sacred
cow is attacked in any way people get
upset and it's understandable
this next one did not run in the paper
it's a sketch but it was after the the
Boston diocese got into all that trouble
with a pedophile scandal and at the same
time they were still looking for Osama
bin Laden so I did this cartoon I heard
this was a good place for evildoers to
hide
yeah they didn't even let this get past
the sketch stage now you know I have had
cartoons that that were approved and
they and they got him they got into the
end of the paper at least you know
enough for me to leave that day and then
I wake up the next morning and open it
and it's not in there and one of them
was after a similar incident where there
was a pedophile scandal in Cincinnati
and it was right around Christmastime so
I had a little kid standing in front of
Santa Claus Santa Claus is reaching down
and the little kids looking at him and
saying you're not a priest are you and
and so so I came in the next day the
publisher had decided at the last minute
to kill it and and I get this phone call
like a couple days later from one of my
syndicated clients because it went out
for syndication and he said wow we're
getting all kinds of letters down here
in Florida on this cartoon that you ran
it's a piece of work he's like what kind
of response have you gotten and then
when I told him what happened he said he
said coward you know he called the
publisher a coward but so yeah this is
uh and here this one was just a funny
one I thought but you know just about
all that all the times they want to put
the Ten Commandments up outside of
government buildings so I just sort of
made up other religions you know ten
laws of Zen howdy-doody ISM that's
that's my religion the ten tips of the
cult of the grilled cheese version ten
commandments of NASCAR in the area 51
disciples credo comparative religion
2004 are you a Mel Gibson Catholic no
more of a Richard beer a Richard Gere
Buddhist I'm a Cat Stevens Muslim
I prefer Madonna's Kabbalah I practice
Adam Sandler Judaism
I just think it's funny how we look to
the stars to tell us who we should
believe in or how we should worship you
know I hope they can keep religion out
of the presidential race
too late this of course was when they
were going into the churches and and
wooing the the friendly congregations as
they called them and and scaring them
with you know whether the gay marriage
thing you know how that's going to
really destroy us this was this was
Bush's Middle East
democracy garden and this was after you
know he watered it a little and there's
Hamas winning the election and he's like
oops then after the Danish cartoon
situation I did this cartoon it was just
basically sort of a caricature of me and
this is after all the violence that
happened surrounding the cartoons
another topic that gets me into trouble
are guns
and here's one I did after the Virginia
Tech shooting this the tragic shooting
at Virginia Tech makes me want to hug my
loved ones and tell them it'll be okay
they're there
this is the NRA saying you can have my
congressman when you pry them from my
cold dead fingers
congressman looks happy know what's
going on there war war is another topic
that gets me gets me some mail I think
it's I think it's interesting that the
us sort of you know tries to spread
peace or at least the the image of peace
but then we're always the one that
making the weapons for all these other
countries so you know it just it just
strikes me as humorous here's one right
as we were going into Iraq you bush
saying you no longer have to live under
the iron-fisted regime of the evil
Saddam we're here to liberate you the
u.s. just transferred sovereignty to our
interim government but all I got was
this lousy t-shirt this doesn't feel
like my flight suit this was right after
Abu Ghraib and that image that images
that they took of the the one guy one of
the things they were criticized for
during this war was that Rumsfeld was
criticized for not properly giving
enough armor to the soldiers and he said
hey you go to war with the army you have
not the army you wish you had and and so
I took that quote and and rephrased it a
little bit and he's saying you go to war
with the arms and legs you have they're
not the arms and legs you might want or
wish to have at a later time so this got
some this got some letters but the most
letters I've gotten ever was that was
this next cartoon and this was during
the 60th anniversary we were celebrating
the 60th anniversary of the Hiroshima
bombing and so I drew this mushroom
cloud on the TV 60th anniversary and the
kid is saying which terrorist group did
that so you can imagine here's here's
one of the letters here the palpable
stupidity of Rogers likening Hiroshima
to today's terrorism should be but is
not an embarrassment to any thinking
person the editor should not be pleased
with what passes as provocative thought
on the editorial page of their papers I
like this sentence is there if there's a
more primitive mind that mr. Rogers
published in the leading
paper of a sizeable US city I'd be
amazed John of Pittsburgh this isn't you
John is it yes so this got me a lot of
letters from you know obviously vets
called me up and said was I saying that
every soldier was a terrorist and I said
no no World War two vets were calling me
and you know and then I ended up writing
an op-ed piece about it and because we
got so many letters so but it's nice
it's nice to have the dialogue I mean
obviously you know I think one of the
reasons we celebrate anniversaries is
because we look back on them and we and
we sort of talk about was it the right
thing to do did we you know would we do
it again I don't think we would do it
again so so that's why in this in this
day and age it would it would seem like
a terrorist attack so here's the real
recent Saddam was found sorry pal but
your spider hole is in the way of our
oil pipeline that's Halliburton there
and then and then remember the
unfortunate photograph of Saddam Hussein
in his underwear on front of the Daily
News or something I did this cartoon at
least you've got briefs this is because
of course we you know we're ruining our
image abroad with the war well you know
they think they found out why Saddam was
acting so crazy he wasn't getting enough
oxygen to the brain as you can see from
this x-ray of his his there was a lot of
lung congestion going on there
another another topic that got me lots
of letters over the last eight years was
was the was George W Bush and the
interesting thing about him is how his
caricature changed as his policies
became more outrageous so this this is
just sort of to show you the evolution
of the years this is how I drew him
actually each of these years so this is
him in 99 before anybody really knew
anything about him and then here he is
in November of 99 I see his ears start
to get a little bigger his eyes a little
closer together here he is in 2000 when
he's actually running and and then in
2001 the years the years are really
growing and now I'm drawing his
is just little dots you know get really
close together and finally here's how I
sort of have been drawing him the rest
of the time so he has devolved we just
celebrated groundhogs day so I'll start
with this cartoon here I was wrong about
him having weapons of mass destruction
but he was still a threat and then I
drew a cartoon after the 9/11 Commission
came up with the evidence that there had
been warnings about what was going to
happen that that actually someone who's
going to you know fly planes into
buildings you know I did this cartoon
it's sort of a take-off it's nice to use
metaphors that people understand like
ground the groundhog or movie metaphors
this is a metaphor for using a Wizard of
Oz so here's Osama saying Surrender
Dorothy all flying planes into buildings
you got the FBI saying what's it mean
CIA it's too vague and Bush saying yeah
and who is this Dorothy character of
course I love Cheney with the Nita heart
sticker on him there
he's the Tin Man of course now back when
when oh this is the only w met speaking
of movie movie parodies
this is dr. Strangelove that doesn't
need any explanation but when he was
running for office or when he was
running again he said you know no he was
going to show no photos of the dead
soldiers returning in the coffins but
then of course his ad you know to elect
Bush reelect Bush showed showed sort of
the heroism during 9/11 and they showed
the coffin of one of the bodies coming
out so so I drew this cartoon we refused
to show footage of coffins returning
from Iraq out of respect for the
families but speaking of coffins and of
course he's doing a dance that one got
me some letters but I do like to use
these speaking about the the movie
parodies earlier when Bush started
hammering away at gay marriage with this
this sort of wedding amendment or
marriage amendment it was about the same
time that the Lord of the
was out so I drew this little cartoon
here it's the Lord of the wedding ring
and he's saying precious distracts from
Trixie Iraq and deficits we loves
precious
I just love drawing him like that I mean
it was just so so much fun and I knew
that not everybody would get it because
I knew not everybody had seen the movie
but I figured you know it works so this
is when he helped open the National
Museum of American Indian this museum
will serve as a reminder when Cowboys
first came to this country and were
greeted as liberators
now this next cartoon was back when I
know if you remember the story about
Jeff Gannon in the White House press
corps who who was always throwing these
softball questions to Bush and he was
very conservative and it turned out that
not only was he a fake reporter but he
was also had been linked to these porn
their gay porn websites and then at the
same time that they discovered this guy
at the same time they they were also the
White House was paying different pundits
to go on and go on the air and actually
tout their policies of you know the
marriage amendment and No Child Left
Behind so I drew this cartoon I've lost
track which ones are we paying and which
ones are giving it away for free I just
I just like drawing the the press car
looking like that
and then the Valerie Plame thing
happened and it was the big leak and and
you know some some cartoons are just fun
to draw like this one was fun to draw
and so was this next one this is Karl
Rove as the the white house
you know fountain and he's saying it's
not a leak he's supposed to do that just
drawing Karl Rove as a cherub was fun
and then of course you know that the
whole scene with with Dick Cheney as
shooting his friend
here's Bush saying don't feel bad dick I
thought I was flushing out terrorists
when I accidentally bagged this one
now speaking of Pope cartoons you know
the Pope recently went to Washington to
visit Bush and and Bush's ratings were
so low that I drew this cartoon here oh
sorry oh yeah I'm sorry I missed one
okay so this is this is Bush commenting
to the press now don't go all negative
when you report this it's fun to use you
know old movie parodies but it's also
fun to use famous photographs that
everyone recognizes because you don't
have to explain the Hindenburg it was a
disaster you know
yeah Iraq war it's a disaster it's
pretty pretty easy to understand okay so
here's the cartoon I was talking about
his approval ratings are so low I
insisted he ride inside
now this next cartoon this got me a lot
of letters as well this is when Bush
made the mistake of saying that that he
had given up golf as his sacrifice for
the war you know when when asked so I
drew this I know how you feel Iraq
forced me to give up golf too now this
this got letters some some people wrote
saying that that they that they agreed
with the cartoon and they thought it was
very powerful image and all that but I
did get some letters from some people
who thought I was using you know these
wounded vets as a as a punchline but I
really you know that wasn't the
intention but you you're always going to
get some of that mixed feedback from
people as I said the serious cartoons
sometimes the subject matter is just too
serious and and people don't think it
belongs in a cartoon no matter what all
right so you know just just sort
summing-up bushes bushes whole thing
here's here's Nixon with Watergate
saying mistakes were made
Reagan with iran-contra saying mistakes
were made and Bush saying mission
accomplished and speak and you know we
were just talking earlier about Cheney
here's one that I did about him this is
not on the government's endangered
species list
the bald ego I like to I'd like to soar
majestically above the laws of man this
was this was the one that this was drawn
after he decided that the Vice President
was not a part of any branch of
government that it was its own ruling
body here they are leaving office and
Cheney's saying I'm gonna miss him most
of all this is the what when the
waterboarding stuff came out is how I
drew Bush and Cheney surfing this is
it's waterboarding is way tubular dude
we're totally shredding the Geneva
Convention illegal immigration not in my
backyard Gitmo prisoners relocation not
in my backyard gay marriage not in my
backyard torture you can use my backyard
all right so those are some of the
topics that really upset people now
we're gonna get it on to some other
cartoons that don't upset people
although you know occasionally somebody
gets upset about these topics too but
not as much do you think math and
science are more important than English
and literature at 7:01 half dozen of
another I actually have been showing
this cartoon for years in schools and if
they don't laugh I know there's a
problem
they're like what I can't wait to start
working in my chosen field
neither can i you're great in history is
a national embarrassment chill out dad
you're acting like it's the Canadian
Missile Crisis or something healthcare
is another one although although you
know it used to not upset people as much
as it does now because it's become a
very polarizing issue but this is these
are some cartoons I've done on it I'm
worried that health care has become too
impersonal doc nonsense just relax and
lie back on the barcode scanner speaking
of which I actually used that cartoon on
the back and that barcode on his back is
the barcode for the book so
I thought that was fun now the one on
the in the original cartoon here is I
think was like a box of Twinkies or
something but the USDA is giving its
food pyramid a makeover what's wrong
with the one we have now sorry pal
there's a five-day waiting period on
that cupcake guess I'll have to resort
to the bake sale loophole this was after
a story came out that said obesity was
now the number one killer the economy
again another topic that you know and in
the old days really didn't upset people
as much but now people are pissed this
is the drugs sort of a falling dollar
you know this cartoon I did in the 80s
1987 actually and and you could run it
today I mean this is about the IRS and
the guy says if you can make it through
our obstacle course you have what it
takes to be a successful IRS agent
number one steal candy from a baby
number two my favorite pummel the bunny
number three tear up an old woman's
pension check and number four kick the
little guy while he's down job
outsourced no health care up to my ears
in credit card debt look on the bright
side no one will want to steal your
identity the good news we've discovered
life on Mars the bad news they're
willing to work for one tenth of your
salaries now this cartoon is sort of you
know harkens back to my my art days you
know I did edward monks The Scream and
sort of combine that with the Starbucks
logo because they were closing all these
Starbucks stores and you know I mean any
time any time Starbucks start to
disappear you know we're in trouble
skip the let tainted toys from China
just leave me cash preferably in Euros
all in favor of a stimulus plan to fix
the salvage plan to prop up the rescue
plan to save the bailout plan we buy
ugly houses banks and businesses now
this next one is just sort of a
reflection on not only you know the auto
industry but my own industry here
dinosaurs in trouble Ford GM Chrysler
and then of course you know delivering
the news extra extra read all about it
yep the environment is another topic
that I like to draw things about this is
back in the 80s when there were a lot of
oil spills all oil tankers spilling oil
she says could you rub some oil on me
dear just wait the tides almost in the
evil queen no pesticides
again with the meta you know when you do
a parody of the you know a movie that's
so familiar to people it's it's it's a
great device because people understand
it immediately this is a different kind
of tree hugger and this is Bush hugging
the logging industry he's so cute
isn't it like a little tree frog you
guys remember the movie the day after it
won at one point in the scene you know
the scene of the movie that the snow
covers the whole place and the Statute
of Liberty is sticking out and the day
after tomorrow and on the plus side we
have finally have an excuse to use our
four-wheel-drive truly American pledge I
pledge allegiance to fossil fuel for the
SUVs of America and to the engine in
which it burns one nation under gas
combustible with carbon monoxide for all
are we running out of time yeah we are
okay
you see what's that okay I'm gonna have
to jump through some stuff here but
equal rights I'll show you these these
two skip that one but this next one I
brought you to the office today honey to
show you what you could look forward to
if you were a man
elections are great this is the Marquis
de Sade and I approve this message it's
going to be a long painful campaign for
Ralphie couldn't even land the Green
Party this time elections of course you
know elect elections of course are the
most fun for anybody alright so here's
what I did about Balloon Boy and sort of
the the you know 24 hour cable news and
all the stuff we you know eat the junk
food
here's can you fix it no unfortunately
24 hour Michael Jackson coverage is
included in the basic package this is
all sort of under pop culture and then
this one the only way the iPhone can
live up to the hype
we've got text we got photos you got
Maps Iraq exit strategy end to global
warming universal health care fair
immigration a cure for cancer and the
paris hilton news blocker
okay so I wanted to show you I wanted to
end with some stuff about Pittsburgh and
you know obviously the this sometimes
these do upset people like the one I did
yesterday but but you know sometimes
they're just for fun and I really enjoy
doing them because they get a lot of
reaction from people locally and one of
the things I do is brood on grant so
that's what I'll start with this was
after we won the Super Bowl last year
and it says Frodo Baggins what brings
you to the fair Shire I'm here to meet
the true Lord of the Lords of the Rings
you mean the Steelers yes they endured a
treacherous journey they were clawed by
Eagles crushed by Giants trampled by
Colson felled by titans but they kept
going they fought their way past the
cave trolls in the orcs even outsmarted
that trickster Gollum see here I used
what Whisenhunt has Gollum me and then
he says what will you do when you find
them get them to sign my cape
get in line have you seen that new organ
transplant show on CBS called Three
Rivers it should be called three livers
it's a little bland I wish I'd had more
local flavor our quaint dialect so doc
canyons guys read up my pancreas in that
our eating habits putting fries on your
sandwich isn't good for your heart who
knew and our sports teams is
Philadelphia an organ donor this is of
course baseball season I'm talking about
here the surgeon could transplant the
Phillies to PNC Park that would be
something to watch all right so just
quickly the last one this iPhone is cool
and of course my depiction of the mayor
is one of the more fun things that I
like to do with with the juice box you
know did did you download the new eye
burg app mayor no I'm playing Frogger
what cyber well it's the first iPhone
application that lets citizens register
complaints with their city I thought
that was what my answering machine was
for people can take photos of local
nuisances and send them to City Hall
cool I'm sending all my picks of Onorato
and City Council haha
including Peduto hee hee you said pedido
can i rig it so it ignores the 311 calls
while I play Frogger I'll bet there's an
app for that all right thank you very
much I appreciate it
you